- I am here with Iliza Shlesinger.
Give it up.
(Kelly cheers)
(Iliza cheers)
- Yeah, (indistinct).
(Iliza laughs)
My next guest was an NBA
superstar who retired
after 12 seasons.
He's recently become one of
Twitter's most popular accounts
with all sorts of heartwarming
and inspirational stories,
funny stories as well.
And he's earned millions
of retweets and followers
including pretty much every
celebrity you can name.
I'm one of them.
Let's say hello to Rex Chapman, everybody.
(drum rolls)
(audience cheering)
First of all, I love your
sweatshirt because I'm Texan.
Yeah, I like it.
And secondly, where are you calling from?
- Lexington, Kentucky.
- All right, South.
All right, well meet Eliza.
Have y'all met before?
I didn't know if you had.
- I just know you played for the Suns.
- I know.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, I haven't met Iliza
but my daughter told me
I had to follow her so
I started following her
and now I'm a huge fan.
- I love that.
- Thank you.
- Daughter tells-
- I'm gonna have to follow
your daughter.
That sounds weird but
you she has a handle.
- I am a stalker.
- I'll do that, great.
- All right, well Rex, how did
this start because you didn't
set out to be popular on Twitter?
- No, I played basketball for a long time
and this just kinda...
A couple of years ago I was
really frustrated with the toxic
social media and kind of wandered off
and I watched so much basketball.
I saw this video of a
dolphin swimming out,
a paddle boarder swimming
in and a dolphin jumped up
and just hit the guy right in the chest
and stupid basketball term I said,
"That's a charge, blocker charge."
Well, I just tweeted it
and people thought it was
kind of funny and then it grew from there.
So yeah, I try to throw in
some feel-good stuff from time
to time to make people laugh.
- I mean that dolphin
video never gets old-
- It didn't charge because
his feet were planted
on the surf board.
His feet were planted.
(Rex mumbles)
Couldn't go the other way
'cause don't have feet.
- Oh my God, you know sports ball?
- I know so much about sports
people are always telling me-
- She does, his feet are set.
Look, that's a charge.
(Kelly laughs)
Exactly, Iliza (indistinct).
- I played YMCA basketball
so I know 'cause I charged
a lot.
- [Kelly] YMCA basketball.
I got a lot of red flags in
lacrosse so I just know about
the aggressive behavior.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I love that.
(audience laughs)
Well, Rex it's pretty cool
to find a way to make social
media help your mental
state instead of hurt it
because I'm gonna be honest with you,
I watched 'The Social Dilemma"
I don't know if you saw that
but it freaked me out.
And I think that it is kind of
daunting the film in general
but at the same time I love
that you've used it to help
with mental health.
And how have you managed to do that?
- Like I mentioned at the
beginning I played basketball
forever and my last three
years of playing I had seven
orthopedic surgeries and
right when I finished playing,
I wasn't a drinker or a smoker,
nothing my whole career.
And the doctor gave me Oxycontin
and that set me on about
a 15-year battle with
painkiller addiction.
I had three rehab stints and
so finally about six years ago
I went to rehab for the third time.
It took that time.
I've been off of painkillers
for about six years
and I know life is hard and
you know heck I lived in my
car for a little while.
I made probably $40
million playing basketball
and since then I've lived in my car,
I've lived on friend's couches.
So I have the greatest debt
of gratitude to so many
of my family and friends who
have supported me through
everything and I think with the
Twitter shoot I'm just happy
to be able to bring a
smile to somebody's face
and I am happy that so many
people share their videos
with me.
None of the contents' mine,
they send it to me I put it out.
- Yeah, well you have made me
smile a lot, you're hilarious.
I love the videos and they
do help whether they're sweet
or they make you laugh, all of it.
You've also used Twitter to
help people financially as well?
- I think the coolest part
about this silly Twitter channel
has been right at the
beginning of the pandemic
I just turned the camera on
myself and put out a video
to these Twitter followers and said,
"Hey, look the times are
tough and people are gonna go
through tough times I believe."
And sure enough we've seen
the ravages of this pandemic
but within about a week
we had raised $300,000
and over the last eight or nine
months we've given out most
of that money in grants in New
York, New Jersey, California,
Phoenix, Charlotte for first
responders, food banks,
on and on just 'cause people
are really struggling, PPE.
So that's been really the best
part and most heartwarming
part about all of this Twitter
stuff is just that we've been
able to help some people.
I'm gonna continue to
try to do so this winter.
- Yeah, it's amazing to use
your spotlight for that.
It's really cool, man.
(audience claps)
As we have discussed, Rex is
a master at finding the most
heartwarming and inspirational
stories around to share
on his Twitter feed.
More than 1 million people
follow along to see what
he's gonna post next.
I wanna share one of his more recent gems.
Rex, before we see it
give us a little setup.
So what do you love about this video?
- Oh man, you know my
my ex wife is a teacher,
my dad was a teacher, my
oldest daughter is a teacher
and I came across the
video last week or recently
that it was...
You know we've gone to
virtual learning online with
many of our classrooms across
the country and I came across
the sweetest video of some
students paying respect to their
teacher on the last day of school.
- Oh, all right, let's roll it.
(wind whooshing)
- [Brown] Seriously, is
it my fault that you have
your cameras off?
- [Valentina] So Dr. Brown
we actually kind of wanted
to do something.
- [Brown] With your camera's off?
- [Valentina] Everybody
if you wanna, go ahead.
- [Brown] Oh, you guys.
You're gonna make me cry, no.
(mouth slurps)
(wind whooshing)
(audience claps)
- So sweet.
We actually have the
professor, Dr. James Brown
which is the coolest
doctor I've ever heard of,
Dr. James Brown I'm just saying.
He's on the line along with Valentina,
the student who organized
this touching surprise.
Give it up for them y'all.
(audience cheering)
So Dr. Brown you must have
been so moved when you realized
what was going on.
My mama was a teacher
and y'all worked so hard
and to actually have that
love reciprocated from your
students is pretty amazing, right?
- It was so emotional
and it was so emotional
for a variety of reasons.
Obviously I was very
touched by it as you can see
but we've been through so
much this semester together,
COVID and the political
climate and then on top of that
I asked them to study some
really challenging subject
matter, the subject matter
is very challenging.
They're studying genocide and
atrocities and I was concerned
about them.
I was concerned how they could handle this
and they did great.
They're so capable, they're so.
- Resilient.
- I'm so proud of them.
I'm so proud of what they
accomplished and some of that
emotion just spilled out
during that class session.
- Yeah, well Valentina,
you actually came up with
the idea, right?
- Yeah, so recently there's
been a lot of trends on social
media of students showing
their professors and teachers
how much they care about them.
And Dr. Brown's amazing
and a few of my friends,
we came together and we
decided that we wanted to do
this for him.
So we private messaged our
whole class on zoom and we got
everybody in a group
chat and basically said,
"Hey, we wanna do this for Dr. Brown.
I know we've had a really
tough semester but he's always
there for us," and everyone
was on board right away
because everybody loves
him so much and has so much
respect for him.
- Oh that's, well 'cause
his name is Dr. James Brown
but I'm just saying it's a cool name.
What makes Dr. Brown so special
to your class, Valentina?
- He is one of the most
compassionate educators
I've honestly ever had.
He made our first semester
so memorable and especially
because we're a class
of first year students
and even online he's gone
above and beyond to make sure
that we feel safe and happy
and everything throughout
the class.
In a regular year he even goes
as far as to invite students
to his house for Thanksgiving
if they're not going home
for the holidays.
- Oh my God.
- [Iliza] That's so great.
- Now, we're crying (indistinct).
(audience laughs)
Valentina, did you think
Dr. Brown would react
so emotionally?
What did you think was gonna happen?
- Oh, not at all.
He's a very compassionate
man with a lot of empathy
and that's what he teaches
in class a lot too.
So when he started to get
emotional I even got emotional
and a lot of people don't
think that teachers are in the
same position as students right now.
You know teachers and professors
are struggling just as much
as students are with the
virtual learning environment
and it's important that we're
showing them that we care
about them and that they're appreciated.
- Was it weird to like
have this big outpour
and this emotional moment
and then he's like,
"All right, let's get back to
our lesson plan on genocide,"
if we can just lighten the mood.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Pick up for the semester.
What was that segway like?
No, I'm sitting here crying
because it's so beautiful
and like I said my mom was a
teacher and she did so much
and I can only imagine, I mean
Dr. Brown how they're talking
about you, how Valentina
and she says her other peers
talk about you.
It's such an important thing.
Teachers do so much and
they go above and beyond
and especially the great
teachers, especially the ones
like she said you're really
concerned and teaching them
to have empathy and character
and especially in such
a hard year.
So anyway, thank you so much Dr. Brown
and thank you everyone for
taking the time to just make us
smile and make us cry
a little bit and laugh.
I love you, Iliza.
(Kelly laughs)